[Music]
the largest private real estate
development in US history open in stores
here in New York on Friday Hudson Yards
on Manhattan's far west side is a
commercial and residential wonderland
featuring some of the city's tallest
buildings and most expensive restaurants
and condos some see the project as a
welcome addition to the nation's largest
city but others think it's exclusive
offerings mean exclusion for too many
Tony Tecopa is at the Hudson Yards Tony
what can you tell us
well good morning I can tell you that we
are a long way from the New York of
subway rats and hot dog vendors but let
me give you a little tour around that
thing behind me that's called the vessel
it's basically a 150 million dollar
sculpture below me there is a mall where
there are about five places where you
can buy a thousand dollar watch and if
you actually want to live here while a
penthouse will run you about thirty
million dollars but here's the thing
before you dismiss Hudson Yards is just
a billionaires playground consider that
for the East Coast and definitely for
New York it's also a kind of final
frontier ambition is always limitless
but land like this is not you're looking
at the largest private development
project in American history built on one
of the rarest things in midtown
Manhattan underdeveloped land so we're
looking at 28 acres overall 28 acres
Bruce Beal is the president of related
companies a partner in the project known
as Hudson Yards because of the vast rail
yards still rumbling beneath us how do
you build huge buildings on top of
hollow tubes that chains go through
carefully a lot of planning great
engineering we had to put columns down
and bring in seal and actually you know
create the platform that platform spans
four city blocks above an active train
operation that never shut down when we
started this process
everyone's like are you crazy you're
gonna build overactive trains and the
answer was we're never gonna stop the
trains the site includes office
residential and retail space along with
a public park welcome to the
neighborhood and it officially opened
Friday after six years of development
and more than a decade of dreaming by
this man and it'll be a really great
urban space Steven Ross billionaire
developer detailed down to the roots
thank you
I heard he drove around picking trees to
me you know everybody talks about ideas
and to be successful you really got to
be involved in the execution and it's
the details and putting the details
together that makes great projects seven
months ago we suited up with safety gear
Road to the top of the project's tallest
building with a view of the Empire State
Building from above and the highest
outdoor observation deck in the Western
Hemisphere we're more than a hundred
floors up on a deck that will be 65 feet
out and if you're brave enough when this
is all done that's gonna be a glass
floor with a view straight down the main
attraction however is a lot closer to
the ground the vessel is a 150 million
dollar set of staircases to nowhere and
yet I believe you said it's gonna be
what the Eiffel Tower is to Paris for
New York I believe so you even said it's
gonna be bigger than the Christmas tree
in Rockefeller Center 365 days a year
that's what I really saw one more you
called it the future biggest tourist
attraction in New York City I'd stand by
all that okay okay
stepping onto the vessel is free to
visitors people will come to see
something like this it doesn't exist
anywhere in the world but living in New
York's newest neighborhood starts at a
reported five thousand dollars a month
for a one-bedroom anytime you're
building something new it's probably
gonna be more expensive than something
that's older at the moment it's more
expensive you think it's gonna come down
over time
I think the market will reach it you
know and it will keep on growing higher
and higher that's typically happens you
want to get in at the bottom this is the
bottom from what I believe Hudson Yards
will be yeah the Pulitzer Prize winning
architecture critic at New York Magazine
did not have kind things to say about
Hudson Yards he said it is too clean too
flat to art-directed called it a
corporate city-state he had oh he was
all over the place is he right is he
right is it a corporate city-state no
it's not I mean you know first of all
you had a piece of land we're building
over the railroads so wasn't the ability
there was nothing here so it had to be
all brand-new the total cost of the
project is expected to exceed 25 billion
dollars but what's controversial is the
additional 5.6 billion that reportedly
came in the form of tax incentives and a
new subway Amazon was given about 3
billion in subsidies and the pitchforks
came out what were you thinking watching
that saga unfold with Amazon know they
were getting the subsidy they were way
paying for something themselves it was
over a longer period of time the city
was certainly benefitting by the jobs by
the amount of revenue was being created
and everything else which is also true
here you think absolutely I mean nobody
wrote us a check or say here's a subsidy
to go build it the reason we got the tax
benefit right here you were you're in
the middle of nowhere in essence in the
city in New York you had to attract
corporations to come here yeah what
we're receiving we're really incentives
to make sure it happened and Ross says
the work that happened here could happen
in any city I think creating these
live-work-play kind of nodes or
environments this is where people want
to be and it can work everywhere
and guys as for whether it can work here
Steven Ross the developer estimates that
the city will get about five hundred
million dollars in revenue a year and
50,000 jobs as we said this is now open
but open is relative of the vessel
behind me if you want to walk on it
fair warning you're advised to make your
reservation in about two weeks in
advance let's start writing once you
give us a clue in Tony write it down for
us I will as for add but going up that
high that Tony was way up there I
couldn't do that I mean that glass floor
terrifies me I'll do it I'll do it for
all of us I'll do it with a picture I'll
deal with you